the freedom of speech years of freedom
and it like all freedoms it comes with
responsibilities the fact that you're
free to say certain things say about the
Prophet Muhammad or whatever it might be
doesn't mean that you should necessarily
say them I think that people should be
free to say the things that Charlie
Hebdo said but I think Charlie Hebdo
shouldn't have said them they're two
different things one is them believing
that people should be free to say things
the other once you are free knowing how
to use that freedom but what does happen
a lot is that people will use claims of
being offended or insulted as reasons
for shutting down freedom of speech and
that's completely illegitimate freedom
of speech is it is limited only in my
view by the the jurisprudence around the
the First Amendment of the US
Constitution the obvious cliche about
not being able to shout fire in a
crowded theater about about not be able
to incite violence these are the limits
on freedom of speech which a free
society can accept and tolerate but
beyond that people should be free to say
what they like and after that's governed
by morality